of all the movies that have come out
lately I have a feeling this movies
going to be the one that you hear mixed
results on the most just saying in time
now in time stars Justin Timberlake and
Amanda Seyfried I think this how you say
her name ciphered and they live in a
world where the currency of the world is
time you stop aging at age 25 after that
you have a year after that you need to
work jobs do whatever you get paid in
currency of time that's how you keep
living in theory the rich people they
live forever and poor people live day by
day you know how it's a saying you know
like oh I live day by day these people
literally live day by day they don't
make enough money by the end of the day
they just die and so Timberlake kind of
enters the world of the rich with a
mission no he kind of has his purpose he
wants to take the rich people down he
takes a man to ciphered hostage and then
after she gets Stockholm Syndrome they
become like bandits
now the cop chasing him is called a time
keeper and he's Cillian Murphy's Cillian
Murphy's great where has he been
I mean besides doing cameos in like Tron
Legacy glad to see the guy on screen
again he's a good actor he's great he's
great in this movie he worked now I was
hoping for timber like to do really well
in this role cuz I was like alright this
might be a perfect role for him rest
assured he was really good in the movie
there's nothing I really didn't like
about him he was witty he was kind of
badass I liked his character and JT
played him well I made a cipher it was
really good too I mean she's the rich
girl you know she's kind of bratty and
she doesn't know how it is growing up in
the ghetto day by day she's like I was
born with a silver spoon up my ass and
you know ten years of credits you
clearly is wearing a wig the entire time
in the movie but still you know her and
all her witness she's still hot Olivia
Wilde's in it for one second she plays
Justin Timberlake's mom his 50 year old
mom hottest 50 year old I have ever seen
and it's really funny justin timberlake
wakes up he's like i got like a day to
live you know it's just normal
this little girl haslam she's like hey
you got a minute he's like oh take five
minutes you know like brownie Scouts or
something I'm like dude you just gave
her five minutes just gave her like one
hundredth of your life no if I had one
day to live I'd be like look you're
killing me you're worse than a pack of
cigarettes get lost I'm cheap with my
money you should see how I am with my
time so the acting was good the premise
was really good the execution though I
thought it was I mean the guy who wrote
this movie obviously came up with the
economy in his head but I'd like to see
you know how it really worked how we
went from cash currency to time because
obviously we spent like hundreds of
years because a guy was like 107 years
and he does not remember when that
system didn't exist and they kind of
sped through things too this is one
point where Timberlake has infiltrated
this you know kind of group you don't
want to see how
happening or like how many days did it
take to do that you don't have days dude
so I feel like it kind of rushed through
a couple parts the concept is badass
there's no denying that that concept is
just great in some parts of the movie
like I've seen that kind of stuff before
the movie doesn't stand out you know for
me I'm like yeah that's pretty good not
great but it's good it's not as good as
you want it to be it didn't feel like
this really unique experience that it
should have felt like in a world where
you know money is time that's a pretty
unique thing I felt like if the movie
dealt with cash currency rather than
time the last half of the movie would
have been no different if there's
something between no alcohol required
and it's okay but you won't remember it
in t-minus a couple days I would give it
that fact here it is I will say it's a
good time no alcohol required at matinee
price yeah that works matinee price for
this movie in this movie would will be a
couple hours so for you what's an
underrated sci-fi movie that really
stands out for you comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more